[Música]
anochecer de verano en la playa
una pareja está sentada sobre la arena
tibia mirando cómo se eleva la luna
sobre el mar
un arranque romántico una ley sea la
otra te regalo la luna
no sé ustedes pero si yo paso por ahí me
paro y en tono firme le digo eso no es
posible el tratado sobre los principios
que rige la actividad de los estados en
la utilización y exploración del espacio
ultraterrestre incluso la luna y otros
cuerpos celestes de mil 967 prohíben la
apropiación de la luna y surge el
derecho civil que nadie puede arreglar
algo que no le pertenece no la jode más
hasta luego
soy abogado espacial eso existe
me dedico a pensar marcos legales para
prevenir y resolver conflictos en el
espacio
pero hay leyes en el espacio
porque debería preocuparme a mí lo que
pasa allá arriba
nuestras vidas dependen del espacio
mucho más de lo que creemos
sin satélites no podríamos ver la tele
mandar un mail realizar una transacción
bancaria buscar una calle en el gps y lo
peor de todo nos podríamos encontrar un
march entender
a diferencia de lo que solemos pensar
hoy el espacio es un ambiente
congestionado un área en disputa y
altamente conflictiva
y donde hay conflictos ya sabemos hay
abogados
pero
qué está pasando ahora mismo en el
espacio
supongamos que en este momento todos
nosotros estamos dentro de una gran nave
espacial y nos proponemos recorrer el
sistema solar
despegamos
todo va bien hasta que aparece el primer
problema
donde empieza el espacio
cuál es la frontera hacia arriba de los
países
no existe consenso internacional sobre
eso y es difícil de lograrlo porque
cuando estableces una frontera le pones
un límite a tu jurisdicción
por ejemplo si el límite de eeuu es de
300 km sobre el nivel del mar en el
kilómetro 301 china o rusia podrían
colocar satélites espías seguimos en la
nave tenemos una velocidad promedio de
27.000 kilómetros por hora cuando de
pronto
nos choca de costado un satélite ruso
fuera de servicio
que no soy un panel solar y nos rompe la
antena
quién es responsable
cómo se demuestra la culpa en el espacio
existe seguro contra todo riesgo
esto no es nada extraordinario de hecho
es cada vez más frecuente porque nadie
se hace cargo de la chatarra espacial
hoy en día el 94% de los objetos en el
espacio son basura
es como si el 94% de los autos que vemos
en la calle fuera chatarra abandonada
incluso peor porque esa chatarra se
mueve a 27.000 kilómetros por hora
pero seguimos nuestro viaje por el
cosmos luego unos meses paramos un
asteroide a estirar las piernas y cargar
agua para el mate
y descubrimos que contiene metales
pesados como oro y platino así que
decidimos llevarnos un souvenir
está establecido que la luna los demás
cuerpos celestes son patrimonio de la
humanidad y no le pertenecen a ningún
país o empresa
pero qué pasa por ejemplo con los
minerales o el agua extraído de los
asteroides
está permitida la minería de asteroides
parece ciencia ficción pero no lo es
de hecho eeuu y luxemburgo ya
sancionaron leyes que regulan la
explotación de recursos naturales en el
espacio incluso argentinas en un
proyecto de ley similar en el congreso
se nos acaba el combustible así que
regresamos a casa
pero el poco tiempo recibimos una
factura por el estacionamiento en el
asteroide
suena raro pero esto ocurrió en el año
2001 cuando una sonda de la nasa llamada
gear aterrizó en el asteroide eros
un año después la nasa recibió una
factura por el estacionamiento de la
sonda en el asteroide con una tarifa de
20 dólares por día
la factura y la intimación al cobro
provenían de un tal gregory hits que se
decía el propietario del asteroide
basado en derechos otorgados por la
constitución de los eeuu
obviamente la nasa respondió de forma
negativa pero limits insistió y decidió
llevar el caso de la justicia se
necesitaron tres años la intervención de
dos tribunales para rechazar
definitivamente la demanda
hay un tema del que no les hable
me preocupa especialmente
la militarización del espacio
desde la década del 60 existe presencia
militar en las distintas órbitas de la
tierra
pero ahora estamos frente a una nueva
amenaza
que el mismo espacio se convierta en un
nuevo campo de batalla
en los últimos años las potencias
intensificaron su actividad militar en
el espacio donde ensayaron distintas
armas como misiles que destruyen
satélites o satélites que chocan unos
contra otros
lo que se llama kinetic kill o muerte
por movimiento
a partir de esto eeuu decidió crear para
fines del 2019 una nueva fuerza armada
en el espacio llamada space force
lo que hasta ahora veíamos en las
películas hoy comienza a ser realidad
estamos en el amanecer de una nueva era
espacial y nos proponemos ser una
especie multi planetaria
las actividades espaciales han generado
innumerables beneficios
pero también enormes desafíos desechos
espaciales minería de asteroides
privatización del espacio turistas en
órbita bases permanentes en la luna
colonización de marte y la
militarización del espacio esos son
algunos los temas que debemos resolver
los sábados espaciales
pero se abren nuevos interrogantes
como debemos gobernar el espacio en el
futuro
el espacio es un lugar donde hemos
competir o cooperar
el espacio es una fuente infinita de
sueños y allí se encuentra el futuro
colectivo de la humanidad por eso para
mí el gran desafío del derecho espacial
está en garantizar un enfoque racional y
responsable en el uso del espacio en
beneficio de toda la humanidad
para no cometer en el espacio los mismos
errores que cometimos en la tierra
pero principalmente para mantener vivos
esos sueños
[Aplausos]
igual si me ven en la playa quédense
tranquilos que no los voy a demandar si
es necesario yo también regalo la luna
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]